Do you think everyone needs to be taking fish oils?
No, I don't I don't think everybody needs to be taking fish oils quite honestly. I don't take fish oils
I don't think everybody needs to be taking
tons and tons of supplements
Period because I think supplements are supposed to supplement your diet. Yeah, but don't I mean our diets are so poor now our
Soil is so depleted and we're deficient and minerals and nutrients. Yeah, that's why you do take supplements
That's why you try to eat better. That's why you try to grow your old food. That's why you try to do those things and yes, you do take supplements
Does everybody need to be on fish oils? No, I don't think so, but fish oils are so good looking all these articles that show how
Beneficial fish oils are and stuff
Well, if you feel like that you need to be personally taking fish oils and by all means do it
I try not to put people on some a little bit overlord where they just burn out
They can't take anything anymore because they're just fried so
Fish oils is not one of the things that I readily recommend. I think you should be getting your fats through your foods
So now if you are on a vegetarian diet
Yeah, you probably need to be adding oils
Advanced to your diet, but even vegetarians are smart enough usually
You know well-trained enough to be cooking in good oils and things so they're getting oils in their diet. I
Just don't I just don't think you know what God created us that you know, he put cold water fish
you know in
You know initially put us in a garden in the middle of a desert. So I mean people live in deserts
People live in I mean, there's people groups that live off of fish oils. You know that eat just fat
from cold water fish and they survive and they don't seem to get any vegetables
There's people groups that have never seen a fish cold water fish are fish well in their life and they seem to flourish
So it depends on your body type it depends on your needs. There's genetic factors that feed into this as well
That's when we look at what people's genetics sometimes people do need more
oils and
their diet
But I've not wanted to say that everybody's be taking a hundred different supplements. I just I don't do that and I
don't think people
In general need to do that
I think there's people that are well-benefitted from taking fish oils. Don't get me wrong. I don't eat the fish oils by any means. I don't think
You know, there's I don't think there's a whole lot of supplements that
Quotal quote everybody needs to be taking
So I think supplements should be used to supplement the person's diet and I think there's different times in one's life
That you need more minerals like we discussed earlier in today's call
There's different times in your life. You may need more oils. There's different times in your life. You need more immune support
There's different times in your life. You need less of all those things. So I think you need to balance that out